this is uh
a messy show with messy characters which
makes them feel very real
so
what made you want to be a part of
telling the story was it that was it the
fact that you could just play characters
that weren't ever going to quite get it
totally right
definitely it definitely was a part of
the appeal uh because it like you said
it felt real
um and it's you know as an actor you
really want to uh
play people you feel like you can
recognize that other people will
recognize and
uh see aspects of themselves reflected
back
in an honest way and the other big draw
for me was just the amazing amazing
women involved you know leslie hedland
jenny connor
i loved simone script
um
so yeah all of those things combined it
was just kind of like a oh yeah i want
to be a part of this
yeah ali how's it for you i mean you've
you've been doing this a while so i
would imagine you know you can get a
sense from a script from the people
you're working with if it's something
you want to do
so what was it for you
that what you just said it was that it
was the people involved the creative
people the creative the producers jenny
leslie simone um
the writing
i loved uh and this character and the
dynamic the the relationship between
carol and sam um but then sophia made
this entire show work for me i just have
to say
she did and our all our scenes together
are
dynamic together our energy together
joy just joy
i mean ellie you've been in this
business for a while so what keeps you
acting i mean do you enjoy the same
things about it now that you enjoyed
when you started doing it or has that
changed and evolved over the years
it's changed um
i mean i i really i love
being able to work on something when it
can be like this
do you know
it's
it's not always like this like the way
that this show felt and was
um
and there are other things i love to do
you know i'm a teacher i love to teach
and i do freelance book editing so
there's a whole bunch of stuff that i
have going on i love acting i really
miss it when i haven't done it for a
while i know that i truly love it but
it's the um
the experience of
the particular project this one
was just a joyful experience
so yeah i first became aware of you and
your work on the american version of
skins
how different do you feel as an actress
on a tv series than you did when you
were an actress on that tv series oh my
goodness well you know as different as a
person feels 11 years later in their
life you know i was
i was 19.
uh when i made that show it was my it
was my first real acting job
um we shot the pilot i was still a
senior in high school you know it's like
i just turned 30 so there's a big i
would hope there's a pretty big
difference
uh in who i was then and who i am now
um
and uh i was just so green and
uh
confused most of the time
um
i mean i'm still i'm still sort of a
confused person but
uh
um
i've definitely grown i think to
appreciate the craft of acting more i
think that i
i hope that i have like deepened what
i'm capable of and
i definitely am way more drawn to comedy
now than i was at that age so yeah i
feel i feel very very different as a
person and as an actor
one of the things i remember most from
watching this season is the moment when
samantha climbs onto the lower shelf in
the grocery store and goes to sleep
behind the cereal boxes
so what what was it like to shoot that
how difficult were the logistics of
actually getting in there behind the
cereal boxes
um honestly i was i was very tired a lot
of times when we were shooting this show
it was i
so grateful for the for the gig and the
experience it was it was quite a lot of
work so i i was just tired all the time
so i was very very happy to have a scene
where i was lying down it didn't really
matter that i was on a cold shelf it
didn't really matter that i was behind
cereal boxes i was just like i i i'm
ready to shoot this all day it's great
uh it was so it was really nice for me
yeah there was just something so funny
about it because i don't think i've ever
seen a scene like that before
it just it says a lot about what the
show is which i kind of love
yeah yeah it's very it's a very specific
and weird thing to do which i think
means it had to have happened
does that mean it wrote it
um
and as somebody who can fall asleep
really easily at work uh i i was like
yeah i buy that
i love what we get to see of the dynamic
between these two characters
when did you guys first meet each other
and
did you spend a lot of time figuring
that out it was a constant conversation
about
who they were to each other
we first met in chicago um when we shot
the pilot and it was it was really sort
of uh an instantaneous bond between ally
and i i've been a fan of hers
for so long it was such a dream to work
with her and um and then to just sort of
like become her friend and for her to be
so fun and cool and nice and
easy and a great hang you know that was
just like icing cake
um
and and i think the carol sam
relationship for both of us is the heart
of the show and kind of the show to us
so
we both took it really seriously and
really wanted it to be
uh
you know
uh special because it felt special to us
um but but in working together at least
for me it was so easy right from the
jump and i think we both saw
their dynamic in the same way
so it could just be playful you know and
we could find stuff on the day and it
was a constant conversation um and still
is ali and i still like chat about where
they are and what they did and where
they'll be where they might go
uh
yeah
yeah i love it because it's not expected
i mean when you see somebody like
samantha you figure like her home life
must be horrible that these two people
must not get along or they're trying to
tear each other's throats out all the
time
but there's something just so
interesting and different and unexpected
about this dynamic
i think i think simone did a really
great job um of not making uh
everything feel sort of like the
stereotypical version of it of itself
you know and
and she just really wrote uh what she
knew and the truth and i think so many
mother-daughter and just parent-child
dynamics are never like just one thing
yes some of them are that really dark
sort of abusive traumatic all in that
universe
um but i at least from my experience and
from my point of view most of them are
like very much in the gray area in
between so i love the way she wrote sam
and carol is like they love each other
they're so passive aggressive
they know exactly how to push each
other's buttons um
it's it feels so juicy which ally has
said a lot and i think is a really good
word
yeah
yeah ali how does carol feel about sam
moving back home i mean does she have
any faith that her daughter is going to
get it together this time i mean what
what are her feelings
at the start of this journey for
samantha
so at the um the whole thing is
horrifying i had to pay for rehab blah
blah um
then it's um okay we're gonna try so
she's gotta move back home i'm not
thrilled uh but i understand it's the
situation she doesn't have any money she
doesn't have a job she doesn't have this
that the other um so she comes home but
then it's just right away it's it's it
it's another disaster right away right i
mean she
she wrecks my car
and she gets up in jail
you know immediately so yeah yeah yeah
she's going to go to the meetings she's
going to do this she's going to do that
do i believe that she's actually going
to pull this off and get sober and
change her life and all this stuff no i
actually don't
i don't
but we'll see i mean i want to see sort
of how's it going to play out you know
and it just takes a while
to watch her
moving through and just beginning to get
sort of like the dregs of her life sort
of together that gives me a little bit
more
uh
faith in her but there's a very long way
to go
i i love too that she doesn't really let
it consume her she has her own life she
has things that she does herself and
she's gonna go on doing them
even if her daughter is
you know doesn't get herself together i
kind of love that it's complicated
though because i ask carol i can tell
you yes
and i am doing what i want to do and
she's not going to come in here and you
know and cross all my boundaries or do
my this or that but if i if she doesn't
if
if i texted her and she didn't text me
back
i would be thinking about it obsessively
do you know what i mean where is she was
she doing
um and then fighting with myself against
like caring too much or thinking about
her too much or letting her take up too
much space there's just an inner thing
going on uh hard to describe
uh and then there's so that was going on
with me and then there was the dynamic
with um with sophia
in what ways do you think
her mother is the bane of her existence
and
in what ways do you think she really
appreciates having her mother there even
if she wouldn't say
so um i think that it is a lot easier
for sam to blame other people
uh for where her life has ended up and
uh
for her pain
and carol is her favorite person to
blame stefan
um and i think as as the season
progresses as sam sort of moves through
her journey of recovery and sort of
reinvention
i i think she starts to take a little
bit more responsibility and in doing so
can kind of see that maybe not
everything was carol's fault
which is a really hard thing for her to
accept
um
i definitely don't think she's the bane
of her existence i think in a lot of
ways they're they're way more similar
than they'd care to admit
um and need each other a lot more than
they care to admit like ali said you
know they can have their own lives and
and
say i wish i didn't have to deal with
this person but at the same time they
think about them a lot
uh it's it's it's a um
i think a really beautiful relationship
and and of course at the at the center
of it is this like gaping hole of their
loss and their grief and um
it's kind of the elephant in every room
for the two of them
so um yeah i think i think that that
grief has affected this relationship in
a lot of ways as well
when you're trying to get sober and turn
your life around knowing that your
former best friend is going to marry
your ex doesn't really seem like it's
going to help keep you on that new path
very well
right
how challenging is that for her to have
to continue to deal with and face
because
i i would imagine nobody would want to
have to deal with that by choice
i don't think so either um yeah
that always seemed so
hard for me i uh i feel like there's
like a really strong girl code and that
is uh yeah just not something you do but
also
you know
sam was a was a bad friend long before
um
uh brit did that to her
uh or you know
i and it's just kind of another aspect
of the way in which sam sees herself as
the center of the universe i think you
know this was her relationship with joel
was this kind of high school juvenile
thing
then and she
sort of ended it with him and she kind
of messed that whole thing up and then
years later her you know she finds out
her her old her ex-best friend is
in love with him and somehow
makes that all about her
um
uh
and is just yet another thing that she
needs to deal with in on this journey of
recovery and and
um you know it's like they always say
there's like never a perfect time
to change there's never a perfect time
to quit
um there's never a perfect time to give
up your advice it's like if it wasn't
this it'd be something else
you know um
this does happen to be a really
challenging thing for her to deal with
but uh yeah it's a tv show so
yeah i gotta gotta have the drama yeah
yeah well ali if there is a second
season of this show are there aspects of
carol that you'd love to get to explore
or see explored because it seems like
there's just so much about her we don't
know yet yeah
absolutely and i think this the
relationship with with sam has a lot of
places to go do you know a lot of layers
a lot of un
un
explored
stuff
um
it's a it's a very i mean look she's
sam is 27 right 29
29 if we do a second season okay so here
we go 29 year relationship i've had
with this kid with all of this stuff
going on um and he's still figuring the
whole thing out and who am i without the
my husband and without that particular
role i don't think i really have an
understanding of who i am so
carol i'm talking us um speaking of so
that's all this thing about you know
okay
do a little dating and how's that gonna
go and
and this ridiculous
scenario with the book club and i just
think it's um
trying to figure out okay what is my
life gonna look like now do you know
yeah so there's a million places to go
to that it definitely feels like that
back and forth between like what what am
i supposed to represent and what do i
actually want to be
yeah what do i want to do do you know
carol's in her 50s i'm in my 50s and
it's just sort of okay so you get to
this particular point and it's just what
do you want to do now like we've done
this done just done this what i want my
life to be yeah you know
well how do i want my relationship with
my kid to be all of that in the 50s is a
very it's a very interesting time and
i'm i'm 59 so i've already even been
through that you know all the 50s it's a
it is a time of reinvention
definitely
well thank you guys for talking to me i
love the show i love your relationship
and i want more of it so thank you very
much thank you so much
you